every mythology has stories of
terrifying monsters enormous dragons and
multiple-headed serpents are not too
uncommon in ancient civilization it's
these types of monsters that are
normally considered the Apex or the
origin of all other monsters in
Mesopotamia this title fell to the
primordial deity tiermat however there
are also stories that would suggest she
was much more than just a monster she
may have been the creator of monsters
but she was also the creator of all life
Mesopotamian mythology has various
different stories of creation and most
of this we can attribute to rivalries
and discrepancies between the Sumerian
cities as today's topic is Tiamat we can
examine the enuma aylish the Babylonian
creation myth which was recovered in
1849 written on seven clay tablets in
Acadian
before we delve any deeper a quick word
from today's sponsor Babel a fantastic
resource for learning new languages one
of the goals I set myself this year was
to continue learning various different
languages because when traveling you
never know which one might come in handy
it's also quite useful for me when
researching video topics from all around
the world to have a basic understanding
of that given language I began using
Babble on my desktop but switched over
to the app on my phone when I realized
how easy it was to use on the go there
are numerous ways you can learn ranging
from beginner to expert and Babel
doesn't just teach you vocabulary you
learn about different Regional dialects
history and culture I tend to stick to
the 10 minute lessons as you can fit
them in whenever you have small amounts
of free time throughout the day as
you're about to see the language I chose
was Spanish
La Jama
edos
edges
Majorca mayorka
La paella
if you'd like to start learning a new
language you can use my link in the
description to get 60 of your
subscription if you do choose to do so
feel free to share what language you'd
be interested in learning in the
comments section or perhaps even suggest
one that you think I should consider
learning next
this creation myth begins as most do
before the creation of the world where
there only existed a singular body of
water swirling in the chaos this body of
water was divided into two and thus the
first two primordial beings were created
from the sweet fresh water emerged the
God abzu and from the bitter salt water
the goddess tear met from their Union
other deities were born lamu and lahamu
followed by ansha and Kisha from anshar
kaima Anu the primordial deity of the
sky and from Anu came enki the god of
water and knowledge all of this new
creation would change the dynamic of the
world forever the chaos caused by these
children Disturbed Tiamat and over time
her disapproval and contempt for her
children grew and grew absu tried to
rein his children in but the calm that
Tiamat yearned fall was no longer
achievable he took his concerns to the
deity Mamu hoping that he would be able
to help Tiamat come to a solution mamu's
solution however was not the answer absu
was looking for he proposed the only way
to end the chaos would be to destroy all
of the new Gods absu without an
alternative course of action agreed his
children however were not so oblivious
and had heard of his extermination plan
enki had prepared a spell that would
Place absu into an internal Slumber when
Mamu had heard of what had happened he
tried to wake absu when enki and the
other gods found him they Chained and
locked him away with absu wearing absu's
crown or Halo enki enjoyed this newfound
power and so to make this permanent he
killed absu with absu's remains enki
created his home inside of absu's heart
enki and his wife damn Kina created
their son Marduk of all the gods Marduk
is described as the most spectacular
tear Max hearing the news of her
husband's death was full of Rage if she
disliked her children before there's no
doubt it was now full-on hatred she
turned to the God kingu for counsel he
advised his mother that the only way to
avenge the death of absu and stop her
children would be to go to war timet
presented kingu with the tablet of
Destinies which made him the new king it
also meant his leadership could not be
challenged making him the perfect
General to lead her Army this is where
we get the concept of TMS as the mother
of monsters in order to challenge her
children she created 11 hybrid creatures
the venomous snake the Great Dragon the
exalted serpent the Furious snake the
hairy one the big weather Beast the Mad
lion the Scorpion man the violent storms
the fish man and the bull man
Anki hearing of this new Army sought out
the Council of his grandfather ansha who
insisted that enki would have to find a
way to appease Tiamat but also feared
that he was not strong enough to face
TMS and survive he proposed that they
elected a new Champion enki's son Marduk
was young but he was the strongest
Champion they had Marduk came before
anshar with only one question which God
would he have to slay to which ansha
replied his opponent was no God but the
goddess tear met Marduk confident of his
victory accepted but only if he was to
be proclaimed the supreme god with
authority over all others after some
deliberation the gods accepted his terms
and gave Marduk the throne before he set
out for battle he was visited by the
gods who prepared him he was given a my
AC scepter and the armor to protect him
he also received a bow a quiver a mace
control over the Four Winds and bolts of
lightning Marduk also had imhulu his own
weapon known as the evil wind Anu
presented him with a net and his body
was set Ablaze Marduk rode into battle
on his Chariot and when he appeared
before Tiamat he trapped her using the
Four Winds given to him he then accused
her of making kingu an undeserving and
unrightful leader all of the trouble in
chaos in the universe was caused by her
this was enough to goad her into
engaging him by herself tier Matt tried
to swallow Marduk but with the Nets he
was given he was able to maintain
distance using the evil wind he was able
to fill her mouth until she became so
bloated from the pressure that she was
unable to move Marduk took his bow and
fired an arrow at the helpless tiermet
piercing her heart and killing the
goddess the other gods attempted to flee
but Marduk captured them tiamat's
monstrous children were also captured
using arnu's net and they were chained
away some accounts believe Marduk
chained these creatures to his own feet
as an ever-present reminder of his
victory other accounts state that these
creatures were chained at the foot of
the Gate of abzu the tablet of Destinies
was taken away from kingu and Marduk
took him to the angel of death he took
the mace he was given and smashed him
at's head the blood being Carried Away
by The North Wind the river's tear griss
and Euphrates were formed from her
weeping eyes and the Milky Way was made
from her tail Marduk then split tier
Matt's body into two using one half he
created the heavens or the Sky our new
enlil and enki were appointed duties in
this particular domain the other half
was then used to create the Earth morduk
then separated the gods to serve above
and below 300 in the heavens and 600 on
Earth he created the constellations in
the image of the Gods as well as the sun
and the moon which then created a way to
define the days of the year as there was
now a night and day cycle it was then
decided that Marduk would create mankind
using his own blood and they would serve
the gods enki and the other gods thought
it would be best if a God was sacrificed
instead and so kingu was chosen from his
blood mankind would be created
from this creation story you could paint
TMS as this big bad evil entity but
there really isn't a good or bad side in
this story it's mostly just chaos the
term used for the events in tier Matt's
story and many others across the world
is chaos camp this refers to the void
state or a state of emptiness which
comes before the creation of the
universe you can look at Tiamat as a
physical monster or as the
personification of primordial chaos in
Mesopotamia Her Image gradually began to
swing more to the evil monstrous side
the brave hero who slays the Monstrous
dragon or serpent is a story as old as
time itself marduk's defeat of tier
match would eventually come to symbolize
the Triumph of good over evil Babylonian
Kingdom celebrated this story as yearly
tradition the representation that law
will always overcome lawlessness unlike
the enuma aylish the other creation
story involving tiermet portrays her as
a beautiful woman known as the
glistening one just as water brings life
to so many here she is a peaceful
Creator goddess there are no issues
between tier Matt and her children and
through many generations the cosmos is
slowly formed modern depictions and
Inspirations of tiermet generally play
on the more monstrous side and often
relate to creatures such as dragons
whenever we see tiramat in any kind of
modern fantasy more often than not she
is an evil chaotic monster which may not
be entirely true but it does make sense
for numerous reasons the creation story
of anuma Elish is a much more developed
story than the alternative it's also in
line with the change in attitude towards
tiermet from the Mesopotamian people
themselves
if you've enjoyed this look into some
Mesopotamian mythology then let me know
which figures and deities you'd like to
see covered in the future
[Music]